hello everyone and welcome to another
great game from the chest 960 Tournament
of the Champions Showdown Italian
and it's um the placement of the pieces
in this game is uh very very similar to
actual chess and not right from from
move one but you'll see uh somewhere
around move 10 move 11 you will probably
not be able to differentiate this game
from a normal game as it's really uh so
what I'm trying to say is that uh
players will get a fairly familiar
position very very early on so I
consider this to be an actual chess game
so let's dive straight into it alireza
has the white pieces and he opens with a
C4 and alireza is trailing by one point
uh nepo is four out of four in this game
this is a game from round five algireza
is on three out of four so a win against
Nepal would tie him for first place so
here we have C5 uh the English opening
I'm only kidding chest 960 does not have
openings at least not as of yet and they
you know it might have at some point in
the future Knight F3 with Knight F6 uh
Knight to G3 and now Knight the G6 we
have Pawn to D4 sorry about that
uh and here a very interesting decision
from Nepal very very early on in the
game he plays Bishop captures on G3 now
usually you don't want to give up your
Bishop just like this but he has a very
very uh concrete idea H Captain D6 now
he puts all his pawns and dark squares
and he has a light Square Bishop to go
in between those pawns at some point he
might even trade it off for uh for Ali
it is light Square bishop and then it's
gonna be
um well just a normal game so Bishop to
C3 and now C captures on D4 we have
Knight captures and D4 and Bishop to D7
we have castles uh now and there's
nothing in between the rook and the king
and by the rules of Chess 960 we are now
allowed to Castle so castles castles uh
in the now B3 I know this is very
disturbing to some of you but now uh
look at this it's only move nine and we
already have a completely normal
position the kings are castled the
Bishops are slicing all the way to the
king side
uh very very very normal position so
here we have E5 uh chasing away the
Knight grabbing more space in the center
and also blocking the dark Square Bishop
we have Knight back to F3 and now Bishop
to F5 offering a trade of light Square
Bishops with Rook to D1 and now Rook to
d8 with Bishop to B2 and now Bishop
captures and B1 SO trading off one of um
alirez's Bishops and uh here we have
Queen captures on B1 not the root
capture some B1 uh Queen capture some B1
is a bit odd uh as uh from C1 the queen
has access to C3 but probably he wanted
I have control over the over df5 square
nattolas and queen to F5 infiltrating
ideas but Queen can still come to G4 and
that's exactly what nepo plays Queen G4
we have rooked the E1 now preparing to
advance the pawn to E4 and H5 now we
have fonte E4 the queen and the uh Rook
nicely defended so probably that's why
Queen to B1 to also be able to cement
the spawn on e4 and now have full
control over the D5 Square leaving a
nipple with the backwards D6 Pawn so
here Ponte H4 Knight captures Knight
captures G captures and the queen
captures an H4 we have Queen to D3 uh
and now Knight to G4 putting pressure on
the F2 Pawn so Queen to F3 and now we
have Rook the f8
uh preparing to uh blast the position
open with F5 we have Rook 8 to D1
attacking the D6 pawn and now we have
Pawn to F5 not worrying about the D6
pawn queen to G3 offering a queen trade
and here uh Nepal trades uh if you don't
then you're just gonna be left with a
weaker position he captures an F5 and
this one is weak for the rest of the
game so captors we have F characters and
g3 at least this way you get the double
LED as a spawns F captures an E4 we have
sorry rook cappers and D6 Rook to F2 now
gaining some activity here uh Bishop
captures on E5 and now Rook captures an
A2 we have Rook captures and E4 Knight
captures an E5 root captures on E5 and
after this uh capture Fest has been uh
finished uh it is not that the end game
officially begins and as you can see
yeah it's two Rooks each but aldireza
has four pawns nipple has three pawns
but alireza has a double G Pawn so how
can nipple play this okay nipple plays
Rook 8 and he says I'm either getting a
draw here or I might even win this if I
can have my Rook on F2 threaten the G2
Pawn I can never lose this but alireza
finds an ingenious way of stopping this
he plays G4 and now you are of course
wondering how is G4 preventing the idea
of Rook F2 Rook Captain G2 uh well
alireza will demonstrate we have Rook F
to F2 and now Rook to d8 with check and
now it doesn't matter if Nepal goes uh
King to F7 or King to H7 uh he played
King to F7 in the game but if King H7
you just force the king to go the the
full circle Rook H5 Chuck King G6 Rook
the D6 check King to F7 and now we use
this G4 Pawn to deliver this Rook F5
check and force a trade of Rooks that's
how you do it captures captures alireza
will undouble his pawns play G4 and he
will continue pushing with his extra
Pawn so nepo goes King the F7 and he
allows it right away so uh Rook the five
with check with captures captures and
pawn to B6 now stopping the advancement
of of whites being the C pawn and now
Pawn to G4
we have rooked the B2 attacking the B3
pawn and here a very very important
decision to be made for alireza uh does
he defend the B3 Pawn if he plays Rook
to D3 to defend the pawn nipple will
play King F6 put a king on G5 and you
can never win this position so here
alireza decides to give up the B3 pawn
and place Pawn to G5 now he gains full
control over these squares and although
the material will be equal for the
moment uh he will be able to continue
pushing for for more than a draw because
he's uh down by a full point ahead of
the leader nepo he wants to win this
Rook capture some B3 Rook D7 check with
King to f8 and now Pawn to G6 very very
important to stop this Pawn here and
this setup will allow alireza to go for
some very very nasty tricks like Rook to
F7 check then the king moves the king
will have to go this way to defend the
pawn then you will be able to move the
Rook threat and Checkmate and so on so
here Rook a three defending the A7 pawn
and now we have King to F2 now alireza
starts bringing his King into the game
as much as possible for the moment he
cannot cross the third rank but nipple
has to play something he plays Rook A5
goes after the F5 Pawn but now Rook F7
check King G8 and King to E3 now uh so
what can ever play he plays A6 at some
point he wants to play B5 and create a
pass Pawn of his own but now alireza
just plays King to D4 also instead of
just advancing the king the position now
is completely winning for alireza there
is the very interesting Rook to B7
because now you're threatening the cap
from B6 and also you're threatening
Checkmate as the pawn now covers F7 and
H7 and even if Rook captures an F5 to be
able to stop Checkmate you don't care
just King E4 and after Rook somewhere
you have to be able to stop Checkmate
now Rook capture some B6 and if A5 now
there's even the idea of C5 and if Rook
to C8 just C6 if A4 just C7 there's no
defense Rook B8 and it's it's a game if
of course it's captured again Checkmate
Rook here okay root captures on CA
checkmate
so after this A6 move with King the D4
by ledisa also perfectly fine he's just
preparing Rook to B7 uh and then now
Rook the C5 by nipple we have rooked the
B7 going after the pawn and now King the
f8 stopping Checkmate this way uh Rook
captures on B6 and now Rook captures on
F5 we have Rook captures on A6 and now
Rook to G5 attacking the G6 spawn and
not allowing alirez's King to go deeper
into the position and I was watching it
at this point I was watching it live
while they were playing it then the
commentators were very very interested
how how aleriza would proceed because it
doesn't seem like there's a there's a
way to push for for more than a draw
here however there is only one move that
wins the game for alireza so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this incredible idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on being again a
true Master of the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to E6 that's that's the
good stuff yes congratulations to
everyone who found this the point is uh
now that you see it uh of course uh the
king cannot go to F7 and if the king
reaches E7 then the black uh then black
will be able to defend this position
however by playing Rook D6 you are now
uh completely keeping the king out of
this game and of course it was in this
position on move 42 that Yani ponies
should resigned the game and alireza
equalized the after after round five so
four points for for each of them now the
thing is alireza was very very low on
time for the major part of this game I
think at the end of the at the end of
the game I can even check I don't want
to trick you guys like uh at the time uh
he resigned uh nipple had seven and a
half minutes alireza had 11 seconds and
okay you do get a five seconds increment
um after you after we make a move but
still uh there was no way to continue
this and of course nepo knew that those
five seconds increment is more than
enough for alireza to win this but for
those of you who are interested I will
show why it's so overwhelming basically
because C5 C6 C7 and C8 this is
Unstoppable the king is basically like
blacks playing without a king so you can
play something you can move the Rook a
little bit but just C5 and after let's
say Rook the C1 just King D5 Rogue D1
check you're gonna play King to C6 now
Rook C1 King to D6 and after Rook to D1
check now King C7 after Rook to C1 you
advance the pawn to a defended Square
Rook to D1 you're gonna play King to B8
and after Rook the B1 check of course
King to C8 Rook to C1 now the pawn comes
to C7 and that's pretty much it Rook D1
let's say King B7 Rook to be a B1 check
and now you will be able to block check
with the rook and that's it black will
have to give up The Rook for the newly
promoted Queen captures captures and now
uh it uh okay black wolf I have a few
more moves but you are getting
checkmated let's say King E7 King to C7
you don't have anywhere to go King fate
King D7 and once the king moves just
Rook the B8 Checkmate you don't have to
like capture the opponent promote this
Pawn to a queen it is over very quickly
so of course Nepal knew alireza was more
than capable of doing this and he just
resigned in this position
uh so yeah very nicely done I will still
not show the standings I'm going to show
one more game and then we're gonna
discuss the standings as it's also a
very important one for the standing so
we're gonna you know talk about it then
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like I said the position very
very early on
starts resembling normal chess and
basically this is just a normal normal
rapid chess game uh so yeah I would like
to thank Paul certain which Jose Palacio
Felipe Palacio is to Papa and Panama and
Matthew Garner and Luke longboned for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Champions Showdown until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day